in front of us we have another
screenshot from khan academy and i've
modified a little bit so i have a little
bit of extra space it says divide the
polynomials the form of your answer
should either be a straight up
polynomial or a polynomial plus the
remainder over x minus 5 which we have
here in the denominator where p of x is
a polynomial and k is an integer so
we've done stuff like this but like
always i encourage you to pause this
video and work on this on your own and
if you're doing this on khan academy
there's a little bit of an input box
here where you'd have to type in the
answer but let's just do it on paper for
now
all right so we're trying to figure out
what x
minus 5 divided into
[Music]
2 x to the third power and actually i
want to be careful here because i want
to be very very organized about my
different degree columns so this is my
third degree column and then i want my
second degree column but there is no
second degree term here there's a first
degree term so i'll write it out here so
minus
47 x and actually to be even more
careful i'll write plus 0 x squared
and then i have minus 15. by putting
that plus 0x squared that's making sure
i'm doing good i guess degree place
column hygiene
all right so now we can work through
this
and first we could say hey how many
times does x go into the highest degree
term here well x goes into 2x to the
third power 2x squared times and we'd
want to put that in the second degree
column
2x squared you can see how it would have
gotten messy if i put negative 47x here
i'd be like where do i put that 2x
squared and you might have got you might
confuse yourself which none of us would
want to happen
all right 2x squared times negative 5 is
negative 10 x squared 2x squared times x
is 2x to the third power now we want to
subtract what we have in red from what
we have in blue so i'll multiply them
both by negative 1 so that becomes a
negative and then that one becomes a
positive and that's actually one of the
biggest areas for careless errors if you
have negative here and you just want to
subtract it because you know you have to
subtract be like no i'm subtracting a
negative it needs to be a positive now
all right
so
0x squared plus 10x squared is 10 x
squared and then the 2x to the third
minus 2x to the third is just 0. and
then we can bring down that negative 47
x
and once again we look at the highest
degree terms
x goes into 10 x squared 10x times so
plus
10x
10x times negative 5 is negative 50x
negative 50x
10x times x is 10x squared and once
again we want to subtract what we have
in teal from what we have in red so we
can multiply both of these times
negative 1 that becomes a negative this
one becomes a positive
now negative 47x plus 50x is positive 3x
and then 10x squared minus 10x squared
gets cancelled out
bring down that 15.
come on down
i used to watch a lot of prices right
going growing up
never quite made it to the show all
right
x goes into 3x how many times it goes
three times
3 times negative 5 is negative 15
3 times x is 3x we want to subtract the
orange from the teal
and so this becomes a negative this
becomes a positive 15 my or negative 15
plus 15 is a 0 and 3x minus 3x is 0. so
you're just left with 0. so no remainder
so this whole thing you could re-express
or simplify as
2x squared plus 10x plus 3. and once
again if this was on khan academy
there'd be a little bit of an input box
that looks something like this and you
would have to
type this in now if you wanted these to
be exactly the same expression you would
also need to constrain the domain you
would say okay 4 x does not equal
positive 5. and the reason we have to
constrain that is where the whole the
whole reason why we can even divide by x
minus five is we're assuming that x
minus five is not equal to zero and it's
generally not equal to zero as long as x
does not equal to positive five but for
the sake of that exercise you don't need
to constrain the domain like this